2020 is fast approaching and Hollywood's
major studios have lined up a slew of
projects to compete for your film going
dollar some of the upcoming releases on
the calendar or highly anticipated
sequels but that isn't all we're
expecting to see Kristen Stewart has
come a long way since Twilight only two
months after appearing as Sabina and
Elizabeth Banks 2019 Charlie's Angels
reboot Stewart is set to star in
underwater a film about an underwater
research crew who find themselves
trapped following a devastating
earthquake although it isn't slated for
release until January 10th underwater
actually finished production back in
2017 before co-star TJ Miller's career
was quite in the shambles it is now and
as much as one might want to compare it
to other Syfy thrillers like alien or
the abyss Stuart told Entertainment
Weekly that there's more to it than that
according to her it's a really dark
scary meditation on isolation Stuart
won't be entirely isolated in the film
though under waters cast also includes
vincent cassell Jessica Henrik John
Gallagher jr. mom and OHA and Gunnar
right it's directed by William Ewbank
whose sophomore film the signal
premiered at Sundance in 2014 if it
feels like you're having a deja vu film
experience with 2020s The Grudge you
aren't alone based on the 2002 Japanese
horror movie Jew on The Grudge had its
first American adaptation back in 2004
which starred buffy the vampire slayer'
herself Sarah Michelle Gellar the 2004
grudge was rated pg-13 likely as a means
of appealing to the largest Halloween
crowd possible however this new grudge
iteration will head into theaters with a
hard R rating starring John Cho Andrea
Riseborough Demian Bichir Betty Gilpin
Lin Shane and Jacki Weaver The Grudge
tells the story of a house cursed by the
spirit of a vengeful deadly presence
rest assured however that although the
grudge will center on an entirely new
cast of characters there will still be
some callbacks to prior films for the
longtime fans prepare to get spooked
when it arrives On January 10th
if Guy Ritchie's more recent
genre-specific film exploits have had
you questioning his appeal as a director
of peer not Ritchie is getting back to
his crime caper roots with the gentlemen
which hits theaters on January 24 the
film's trailer seems to promise drugs
double-crosses classic ritchie dialog
and duplicity in other words it sounds
like a return to form for the director
of locks
and Two Smoking Barrels and snatch
starring Matthew McConaughey Charlie
Hunnam Michelle Dockery Henry Golding
Colin Farrell and Hugh Grant the
gentleman is the kind of action film
we've been wanting to see from Ritchie
for years in the aftermath of her
family's untimely death Stephanie
Patrick played by Blake Lively heads
towards self-destruction when she
discovers the plane crash that killed
her loved ones was orchestrated she
takes it upon herself to enact revenge
upon those responsible the rhythm
section which was originally supposed to
have made it into theaters at the
beginning of 2019 marks only the third
feature for cinematographer turned
director Reid Morano morano's made a
name for herself on the small screen
though having done work on the
Handmaid's Tale and billions the rhythm
section is written by Mark Brunell who's
adapted his own novel for the big screen
the film looks to be something between a
spy thriller and a revenge thriller with
a strong female lead while lively has
done action films in the past this will
be her first time actually heading up
this kind of major studio action movie
rounding out the cast are Jude Law
sterling Kate Brown and Richard Drake
and the rhythm section arrives in
theaters on January 31st the 19th
century German fairy tale about a young
pair of siblings who find themselves
lost in the woods and end up the dinner
target of a which has certainly seen its
fair share of film adaptations
generally speaking none have been
particularly outstanding and some like
2013's Hansel and Gretel witch hunters
have gone so far off the rails that it's
just sort of laughable but come January
31st we'll get a pretty straightforward
on-screen version of the story
Sophia Lillis who played the younger
version of Beverly Marsh in the it films
leads the cast as Gretel
while Sam leekie makes his feature film
debut as her younger brother Hansel
genre veteran Alice Krieger takes on the
role of the witch hold up gredin Hansel
marks only the third film by director oz
Perkins his previous works are the black
coats daughter and I am the pretty thing
that lives in the house aside from its
character swap title Gretel and Hansel
looks to be an incredibly creepy true to
its source material feature the terror
of isolation is having a real moment in
the horror genre films like 2016's ha
short 2009 teens midsummer presents a
kind of fear that's compounded by the
fact that there is quite literally
nowhere to run so too does the lodge
which centers on soon-to-be stepmom gray
says she struggles to discover the truth
behind the mysterious and terrifying
presence and a Snowden remote
village the lodges is much a story about
a troubled young woman trying to make a
connection with her fiance's less than
enthusiastic kids as it is about the
creepy monster hiding in the snowstorm
grace has a difficult past then it's
hard to tell how much of what's
happening to her in the present is a
direct result of it you'll just have to
see it for yourself to find out On
February 7 Ben Affleck reunites with his
the accountant director gavin o'connor
for the wayback a movie that's happened
inspirational feel-good story about a
man struggling with alcoholism and half
a sports drama about a high school
basketball team that's fallen from glory
in other words pretty much nothing like
the accountant the way back is written
by brad Inglesby whose previous credits
include 2013's out of the furnace and
2019 s the friend the wayback did
experience a development turtle back in
august two thousand nineteen when the
film had its original october 2019
release date pushed back to March six
2020 the date change gave the way back
the opportunity to avoid having to go up
against Warner Brothers already heavy
fall 2019 slate which included it
chapter two and Joker it'll also allow
the basketball centric film to
capitalize on the start of March Madness
nearly two decades after we first saw
charming idealistic law student L woods
demonstrate the perfect bend and snap
Reese Witherspoon is set to reprise one
of the biggest roles of her career with
Legally Blonde three Witherspoon won't
be the only familiar face returning for
the three quote it seems as though most
of the original film's creative team has
signed on as well currently not a whole
lot is known about the pill it's yet to
secure a director and specific plot
details are being kept under wraps
chances are good that Legally Blonde
three will be in line with the two
previous movies centering on Elle Woods
ability to overcome adversity through
optimism ingenuity and sheer
determination the idea with this one is
that it will most likely focus on female
empowerment hopefully introducing the
franchise to a new audience when the new
installment comes out on May 8th Harvard
Law School you got into Harvard Law wait
like it's hard coming July 3rd 2020 is
free guy an action comedy directed by
stranger things Shawn Levy and starring
Ryan Reynolds who might be the only
actor to ever play the same character
twice with completely opposite results
free guy tells the story of guy played
by Reynolds
bank teller who comes to find out that
he is a non-playable background
character in a brutal and violent video
game the film also stars Tycho ITT Jody
comer and Joe Curie and is written by
Matt Lieberman and Zack Penn
there are two big noteworthy reunions
happening with free guy
the first is between kiri and levy who
have a long running history on Netflix
is hit series stranger thanks but
there's also the on-screen reunion
between Reynolds and whitey T who
appeared together once before in 2011's
Green Lantern a racetrack yeah hmm
that's the best you could come up with
first big appearance I'm sorry I did i
disappoint you
Disney has a long history of adapting
its theme park rides into blockbuster
movies Pirates of the Caribbean turned a
15 minute boat ride into a film
franchise that spans five films and soon
a reboot of course it would only make
sense for the House of mouse to want to
expand on its ride to movie franchise
opportunities before Disney Parks are
comprised solely of movie based
attractions the Jungle Cruise ride is a
favorite for weary park goers who are
looking to take a break and listen to
some cheap jokes for 10 minutes
meanwhile the Jungle Cruise movie looks
like it could be another franchise hit
when it arrives in July 24th with a
fresh spin on the rides cornball
one-liners courtesy of star Dwayne
Johnson the actor was originally
announced for the film back in 2015 but
development on Jungle Cruise took its
time co-star Emily Blunt wasn't cast
until 2018 the film's official synopsis
promises to add a supernatural element
to the river bound tail which is right
up director Joe Maine Colette Sara's
Ally is responsible for both orphan and
the 2005 remake House of Wax
just before Halloween 2020 hits will be
getting the third installment of the
conjuring universes flagship series
Patrick Wilson and beer of Farmiga will
both reprise their roles as Ed and
Lorraine Warren although James Wan who
was behind the camera for both the
conjuring and the conjuring 2 is sitting
out directorial duties this time around
he's still on board as a producer though
with the curse of La Llorona director
Michael Chavez taking the helm the
conjuring the devil made me do it is
inspired by the first time in US history
that a murder suspect would claim
demonic possession as a defense that
would be the story of Arne Cheyenne
Johnson who was put on trial for the
murder of his landlord following a
failed exorcism attempt he claimed to
have been possessed at the time of the
kill
we'll have to see if the devil really
did make him do it when the conjuring
three arrives on September 11th venom
may not have been a critical success but
it wasn't long after its 2018 release
that rumors began to circulate regarding
the film's inevitable sequel that was
confirmed in January 2019 and by August
Andy Serkis had signed on as the film's
director Tom Hardy Woody Harrelson and
Michelle Williams will all return for
Sony's second round with the famous
marvel symbiote while Naomi Harris is
rumored to be taking on the role of
shriek Carnage's deadly partner if the
rumors are true that could mean big
things for Sony spider-verse
in the comics shrieks team up with
carnage ultimately led to a face-off
between spider-man and venom along with
a whole bunch of other superheroes
how the whole thing inevitably unfolds
will likely have a lot to do with the
fragile relationship between Sony and
Marvel if the two studios managed to
work things out
venom 2 could be setting up the
framework for a huge crossover when it
arrives in theaters on October 2nd one
thing we know for sure about venom two
and I'll get out of here and I will
there's gonna be carnage
when David Gordon Green and Danny
McBride rebooted the Halloween franchise
in 2018 they took a huge risk
the new film retcon to everything that
had happened in the franchise following
the original 1978 film and picked up
four decades later in a world where
former babysitter Laurie Strode had
spent a lifetime preparing for another
confrontation with her masked stalker
but according to McBride their leap of
Horror faith could have been an even
bigger one
apparently the pair had originally
planned to pitch two films to be shot
back-to-back they ultimately decided
against it but shortly after Halloween
open to both critical and commercial
success two more films were confirmed
slated for October 16 Halloween kills
will seek Curtis again reprise her role
as Laurie Strode along with Judy Greer
is Laurie's daughter Karen and Andy
matichek is Laurie's granddaughter
Allyson it will also bring the return of
several of the franchise's original
characters 1978 babysitting charges
Tommy and Lindsay are back and all grown
up with Kyle Richards returning as
Lindsay all Anthony Michael Hall takes
the role of Tommy
Nancy Stephens and Charles ciphers are
coming back to reprising their
respective roles of nurse Mary and
chambers and Sheriff Leigh Brackett
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]